let's talk about inconsistency for
creatives versus the people that may be
there so on the nose and so precise but
maybe they've lost some of the creative
flair I happen to see a lot of people
that are inconsistent be incredibly
creative and actually have brilliant
ideas
they just don't follow up on them yeah
and then on the flip side the ones that
actually do follow up sometimes the
creativity or the Flair still needs to
be fleshed out so how do you nurture
both types well you really have to look
at writing as a job rather than a muse
right it's Larry karaszewski and Scott
Alexander talk about they wrote people
versus OJ Simpson and Larry Flynt and
and a whole bunch of biopics and bio
dramas and they talk about this is a job
and we go into work even when we don't
feel it and some days the writing is
great in some days it's horrible but
it's the work sometimes you have to
write it through a lot of horrible pages
to get to some good pay pages and I'm a
big believer in that you know sometimes
you have to try something different you
know so it's staying agile and open to
the different ways to access creativity
sometimes it's rejecting creativity and
just going for inspiration and through
inspiration getting back to creativity
but you have to accept that what works
on one script will likely not work on
the next and so you always always always
have new tricks to try and your writing
new ways to access the work new
methodology to follow new things that
will inspire you you know and if nothing
else then you know you go and do
something for fun because fun baguettes
motivation so whether your fun is
dancing or hiking or jogging on the
beach or whatever it is you usually come
back pumped up and excited that said you
know creativity is tough to always
channel so a lot of my writers rely on
meditation on regular workouts on
tracking systems to set their
expectations for what they're going to
create and when you know a lot of self
journals a lot of goals and targeting so
that at some point your your system
begins to understand that you have to
show up
whether you feel like it or not what are
those tracking systems that's really
interesting um there's something called
self Journal a lot of my clients use
that is a planner a task driven planner
with short term goals and long term
goals a lot of writers rely on systems
like Pomodoro that requires 25-minute
sessions so it really varies depends on
the writer but every writer finds their
path so some writers write for page
count some writers write for hour count
you have to find what is your
comfortable space to write three pages
at a time or six pages of time or three
hours at a time what can you meet what
can you meet consistently because it's
kind of like going to the gym first few
days are going to be really really hard
especially when you have in a minute in
a little while on day 12 13 14 you're
going to hit your stride and if you keep
going then you're going to be fine and
it's the same with writing you just have
have to keep doing it in order to get
comfortable with it the beginning is
always going to feel rusty and clunky by
the end you're going to be hitting your
stride
you